so inspired by the new Tom Brady
contract
today's draft this is one of those
wide-open you can take it anywhere you
want type of a thing where we are going
to draft things that we guarantee will
happen before Tom Brady actually retires
I guarantee I will lose the rigged coin
toss Chris so it's on you to go ahead
and call it I predict you're gonna call
tails and it will be tails I know I'm
gonna go heads today because she's gonna
try to get you off in a good mood this
week so see told you I am so do you know
in her head it's unreal
that is your way of deferring you did
not want the first pick because you have
no idea how this is gonna unfold so you
want me to go first direct no I don't
want you to go first I want to I want to
go first I don't I don't care about you
I want to win the draft the hell with
you okay
I'm going I'm going first I was right oh
that's right yeah all right go ahead
yeah go first you know I don't know I'm
sorry I wish I was I got it screwed up
apparently you're flustered yes I don't
know what you're talking about but I
don't know what I'm gonna pick for any
of them I'm glad they don't have to go
further I'm gonna go my first one things
that will happen before Brady retires
the Browns will be in the playoffs okay
it's a little like okay obvious but
still the damn Browns haven't been there
and what 18 years or 17 years so it's
still a little risky at this point we
don't know what they are going to be but
certainly are talented I just look at
Baker Mayfield a quarterback the weapons
Odell Beckham jr. of course the defense
has young talent on it I just look at
everything there I was gonna be bold and
say they host a home playoff game but I
wasn't gonna go to total crazyville
there so I'm just gonna say the Browns
will be in a playoff game before Tom
Brady retires you're really not going
out on a limb though because the guy may
play like five more years I mean the law
of averages tells us the Browns are
eventually gonna get back in that's
really not all that guts you're crazy we
don't know you don't know you're very
much a part of the count the camp that
it Brady won a Super Bowl this year that
it could be it so don't give me this
five-year lawyer crap okay my pick was
very good is bald not a nice
trying to shoot it down stop stalling
and make your damn pick now my pick this
is a very simple one and I think we have
the answer to it by virtue of the
contract extension that Tom Brady just
saw and the fact that he will retire and
have not changed teams he will only ever
play for the Patriots I think that
possibility is is over at this point
however it plays out he will be a one
team guy and he will never play for
another team I mean you're gonna get on
me that I picked a team that didn't go
to the playoffs for 18 years and you're
gonna then you're gonna go Arthur Tom
Brady will stay with the team that he's
been with for 18 years and 160 Rosewall
so bold so Brady's I've played for a
different team Peyton Manning played for
a different team John you Knight is
finished with the charges for crying out
loud
Joe Namath was with the Rams and there
has been this looming possibility on
that magnet that draws him back to San
Francisco and and I think that that we
now know that he's only ever gonna play
for the New England Patriots he will not
play for another team that that is more
of a bold prediction than this idea that
at some point in the next five years the
Browns are gonna make it to the playoffs
you're insane you're absolutely insane
but either way whatever will let the
people figure that out I'm gonna win
this draft either way I don't care okay
here we go
things that will happen okay I'm gonna
go bold here
Sean Payton will have a new QB before
Tom Brady retires okay I'm gonna go
there I don't feel really will be
coaching what is that because he'll be
coaching a different team or because
there'll be a different quarterback in
New Orleans yeah that's where I was
going it could be either one that's kind
of why it went into my head I went oh I
could see maybe Sean Payton leaving
after this year maybe it's two years I
don't know but I think there's a lot of
people that got their eye on that
situation and yeah I can also see you
know Brees having a year where he's not
satisfied with where he's at physically
and everything and he might just say you
know what it's been a great run and I'm
done so yeah it's a little bold here but
I'm gonna go with it I like it I like
the creativity because I had on my list
that Drew Brees will retire before Tom
Brady retires but I like the idea that
however it plays out Peyton's gonna have
a different quarterback whether it's
because he's in Dallas or or elsewhere
or Drew Brees walks away appreciate that
and that's alright I'm trying to help
you out a little bit not next one for me
when tom brady retires Jimmy Garoppolo
will not be the 49ers quarter sounds
juicy you got a reason I think there's a
good chance Gruffalo's got one more year
I just think that that that they're not
sold on him I think that yeah and
they're never gonna admit these things
Chris and I don't know how much you
talked to Kyle Shanahan about this I
have a feeling he's probably guarded
with you now that you're part of the
problem they've got they've got to be
concerned about that idiotic maneuver
week three last year when he when he is
on the sidelines and he and he cuts to
try to throw a shoulder at a defensive
back instead of getting his butt out of
bounds and you know just you just have
to wonder you know they have exclusive
access to this guy are they really up
firm and true believers that he's the
long-term answer when you see what else
may be out there a possibility that Kirk
Cousins could be had via trade for next
year I just think the Garoppolo will not
Bend you know maybe that's one of the
things that will keep Brady going that
he's determined to continue to play
even after Garoppolo flames out in San
Francisco if there's any truth to the
tension the reports of tension and any
type of petty jealousy between the two
of them that's something that would keep
Brady playing because he wants to play
beyond Garoppolo plays in San Francisco
I don't think it's that crazy of an idea
and I mean you're right first of all
Kyle Shanahan when we do talk we don't
talk all that often I always try to keep
my distance because I am part of the
enemy now as far as the media and we
certainly when we do talk we don't get
in to the 49ers but I know him well
enough to know that he's got to be a
little unsettled with Jimmy Garoppolo I
mean like we talked about earlier in the
show before even this draft I mean we
just don't know what Jimmy Garoppolo is
yet so how can you be totally
comfortable as a coach and a GM it's
your third year on the job in San
Francisco the first two years haven't
gotten real smoothly
I'm sure he's wondering how this all
plays out with Jimmy Garoppolo too and I
mean Mike I'm with you too reading the
tea leaves like gosh if things didn't
work out with men
soda and it didn't work out with
Garoppolo and you know cousins in
Minnesota and Garoppolo in 49ers would
something be done there I'm gonna keep
my eye on that you've been saying stuff
like that with McVeigh in the Rams and
Garoppolo and the 49ers with cousins all
along and I I don't think that's totally
crazy so I'm with you there all right
I'm gonna thank you thank you for
bolstering my pic we're even now we're
friends okay so I think all right this
is maybe a little boring but it's not
that boring I mean things that will
happen before Tom Brady retires Patrick
mahomes will have another 5,000 yard
throwing season okay you like that it's
boring that's boring that's boring I'm
sorry well I mean I didn't know 5,000
yards were so boring now oh sorry sorry
for seeing so borsch but I really that's
up [ __ ] that I don't break a single
season passing mark you like that one
better let's change that okay thank you
tonight he's gonna bat swear I'm gonna
go with that because one I just think
this is only gonna go up I mean mahomes
as you've heard me say last year in the
off seat he left a lot of plays and
yards on the field last year I think
just because if he's a rookie you know a
rookie quarterback or first year playing
and experienced all those things but you
know now that Tyree kills back in this
situation and I think we're gonna have a
healthy Sammy Watkins I just go gosh I
just you know I don't stand Andy Reid
doesn't like to run the football anyways
I think that potential is there for him
to break that single season passing
record well that's what I am definitely
gonna write down and hold you to and I'm
gonna alert the folks that old takes
exposed that that that is going far out
on a limb that he's not just gonna get
the 5,000 but he's gonna set the single
season passing yardage record and and
look it's it's hardly impossible for a
kid like Patrick mahomes I mean what we
saw last year I know we're concerned
that maybe the rest of the league is
gonna catch up with him I just don't
think they can no I think when when
things start to break down his physical
ability clearly outshines any of the
other folks who are on the field so I
agree with you that that mahomes is
gonna continue to be special I just
don't know that that yeah I don't know
that I feel strongly should I end up
with the passing yardage record for a
single Smike did you see that thrall you
know that made in kind of the
News this weekend with him scrambling
out to the right and launching that bomb
to McCole Hartman I mean that was unreal
you know I know it's practice and
there's no pass rush there but he threw
that ball 70 yards on the run that is
insane
I mean I just I can't say it enough you
know I mean I don't even know if oh
Aaron Rodgers can do that that's how
special that is I mean are you really
are you really are there's one mahomes
to negative ghostrider but yes it's more
like 1a and 1b but no I'm still breaking
news one eight one eight one a yes all
right my last one is this when Tom Brady
retires Josh McDaniels will still be the
Patriots offensive coordinator see I'm
trying to make mine about the Patriots
as much as I can and links back to the
Patriots McDaniels I think the ship has
sailed on his opportunity to leave I
think whatever went down with the Colts
is causing teams to shy away from him
look at this last hiring cycle no one
was seriously interested in him I think
he's staying put
maybe he succeeds Bill Belichick guard
'less whenever Brady walks away
McDaniels are still gonna be there which
guarantees that Brady's gonna continue
to operate at a high level because he's
not gonna have to go through that
offensive coordinator chain exactly
right I mean he's certainly gonna help
Tom Brady out here through the last few
years of his career McDaniels is awesome
you know I understand your logic there
I'm a huge believer in Josh and of
course I you know I know him I played
for him I worked under him there but
just you know he's so impressive
mentally game plan design the way he
calls plays but I you know I I kind of
agree with you Mike and the fact that I
think if he becomes a head coach
anywhere it'll be in New England because
they really know him understand them and
really get what he's all about all right
did you I did give me one more that you
had that you were thinking about
throwing on the list I was thinking
Carson Wentz wins an MVP or say Kwan
Barclay wins Offensive Player of the
Year I wanted to go MVP there too but I
don't think the Giants are gonna be good
enough to realistically say that so
those were two that I had on my list see
again mine were Patriots focused I was
thinking about Gronkowski will unretire
before Tom Brady does retire
and the Patriots will win number seven
before Tom Brady retires and and I you
know you can make the case for any of
those all of those and I do think
there's a good chance that Gronk will be
back this year all right Sims has Browns
will make the playoffs Sean Payton will
be coaching a new quarterback and Pat
mahomes will break the single season
passing yardage record my picks Tom
Brady will not change teams before he
retires can I finish please and josh
mcdaniels will still be the Patriots
offensive coordinator when Brady finally
walks away
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports